the Heaven and the Earth welcome to Q&A
on the word inspired with elder Randy
ski and today we are discussing the
creation before we begin let's have a
word of prayer dear heavenly father we
bless your name for another Sabbath day
a day of rest and gladness a day of
sweet Repose and father we thank you for
the privilege to be in your presence and
we invite your power your Holy Spirit to
dwell amongst us forgive us of our sins
and I ask in a special way that you
would anoint your man's servant Elder
Randy SK put your words in his mouth
your humility in his heart your ideas in
his mind oh God I pray that you would
even guide the formation of his tongue
dear Lord and his lips as he speaks your
word and I ask that you would bring
people from far and near to hear the
truth of the Gospel the very Foundation
of our being and our and our existence
which is that you are our creator so
guide this session and may we leave
enlightened and empowered to live for
you in Jesus's name we pray amen so
friends those of you are joining to my
left is my dear friend you can introduce
yourself hi everyone my name is precious
and it's a pleasure to be here okay and
today we will be asking the questions
together I do apologize for the
uh video quality for some reason my
camera is not working you know I set up
everything last night and this morning
it's just not cooperating but praise the
lord we are here to do his work and I
would like to invite or rather introduce
our very special guest whom I deem as
family true family our special guest
this afternoon is the epitome of a man
of God Beyond his uh teaching and
preaching all all over the world he is
very humble and is intentional about
making lasting relationships with people
to lead them to know Jesus Christ he
understands the power of prayer and it
often is interceding not only for
himself but for others he also checks up
on those that he has relationships with
I speak of none other than Elder Randy
SK he is Anointed for the ministry he
has studied at Oakwood University
univers and the Andrew University
Seminary and today he will be answering
the questions on the creation thank you
so much for taking the time to be here
with us Elder ski we know you are in
Wayne New Jersey but you have carved out
this time to be with us this afternoon
thank you so
much the pleasure is entirely mine Dr
Denisha I'm always delighted to be a
part of your program that God has given
to you and I say that very very
seriously
thank you for so frequently involving me
and I hope that God will speak through
all of us so that those listening may be
enlightened and drawn closer to him
thanks
again ah amen amen thank you
for even encouraging me to continue this
ministry of bless God for you okay
family so let's delve into our topic
this afternoon which is the creation and
I we want to find out why did God create
Heaven and Earth what was the purpose of
this well we can't enter into all the
purposes of God but the Bible does give
us some Clues as to why God created
heaven and earth uh Isaiah 43:7 tells us
I have created him for my glory that's
humanity and Humanity has to live
somewhere so when we talk of the
creation of man we have we have to
include Heaven and Earth ELO tells us in
the Bible commentary volume 1 page 1081
paragraph 2 God made the Earth to
enlarge Heaven he desires a larger
family of created intelligences he made
the world to enlarge Heaven there's a
sermon I preached many years ago called
the 51st state and Earth is like that to
heaven now very interestingly ELO white
writes in signs of the times April 22
1903 paragraph 5 we were created we were
brought into existence because we were
needed now that always uh baffled me we
were brought into existence because we
were needed but essentially creation was
for the glory of God and so we read in
psalm 19 verse1 the heavens declare the
glory of God and we read in Isaiah 6:3
the whole earth the whole earth is full
of his glory and so for the glory of God
creation was
done amen amen you know it's so
interesting that you brought up that
quote Elder SK about God even needing us
you know I was taking a look at
Patriarchs and Prophets and how speaks
you know the war that began in heaven
and how God needed Arbiters to show that
he is not uh a tyrant and his law can be
kept through his power so praise God he
has given us the opportunity to be coll
laborers with him yes
exactly so let's so let's let's just say
it again all of creation was for the
glory of God and that has not changed so
our life can either support that or
contradict it and the choice is ours we
can so live to support the original
purpose of creation which was and
Remains the glory of God or we can so
live as to fight against that original
purpose and of course those watching are
those who have chosen to support the
original purpose which was and Remains
the glory of
God amen amen if you read Psalm
119 it uh verse 90 89 to 91 thy
faithfulness is unto all generations
thou has establish the Earth and it
abideth they continue this there
according to thy ordinances for all are
thy servants and so we have Heaven and
Earth they continue they are all the
Servants of God so creation was for the
glory of God and was to be used by God
to advance his purposes all of creation
all aspects of creation are servants in
this H in the hand of
God amen amen so now that we have
established our purpose Elder SK which
is to glorify God let's get into how
this creation took place so how did God
create Heaven and Earth and who is the
active agent of
creation uh is your microphone at
maximum I just turned up a couple ah
there you are okay okay thank you that's
all right that's okay perhaps you may
ask the question again in case someone
didn't hear you yes so we've established
why God cre Heaven and Earth which is
for His glory now we want to understand
how did God create Heaven and Earth and
who is the active agent of
creation all right how did God create
Heaven and Earth the Bible is very clear
Psalm 33:6 and verse 9 by the word of
the Lord where the heavens made and all
the hosts of them by the breath of his
mouth you have to ask the question what
is all the host of them living and not
living animate and inanimate El tells us
Patriarchs and Prophets page 38
paragraph 3 he was the son of God ages
before the Angels were called into
existence and Psalm 148: 1 2 and 5 tell
us very clearly they were created by the
command of God or the word of God
creation was by the word of God by the
word of God with the heavens made and
all the host of them by the breath of
his mouth psalm 33:9 for he spake and it
was done he commanded and it stood fast
Hebrews 11:3 through faith we understand
that the worlds were framed by the word
of God second Peter chapter 3:5 for this
they willingly are ignorant of that by
the word of God the heavens were of old
and the Earth standing out of the water
and in the water so throughout we learn
creation was brought about by the word
of God now the agent in creation which
was the second part of the question is
Jesus Christ if you read Philippians not
Philippians Ephesians 3 verse 9 and to
make all men see what is the Fellowship
of the mystery which from the beginning
of the world ha been hidden God who
created All Things by Jesus Christ
Hebrews 1 from verse one God who at sary
times and in diverse manners spake in
time pass unto the fathers by the
prophets has in these last days spoken
unto us by his son whom he has appointed
heir of all
things
father creation Christ is the word and
that creative word we still have with us
today which is the holy
scriptures amen and amen for some reason
the internet kind of broke up there
Elder but we sorry it's okay we were
still able to capture those verses that
you shared before deliv Jesus Christ
active agent
in Creation in Salvation and in
communication with this Fallen World it
is through
Christ amen and the recreation of the
Heaven and Earth will also be through
Christ yeah and about well we may get to
this point perhaps there a question is
there a question about the maintaining
of creation yes that's question there is
okay all right all right okay all right
so the next question will be what is the
relationship between the Sabbath and
Creation in other words how does the
Sabbath help us recognize the power of
creation and remember the things that
God created the Sabbath is inseparable
from creation Genesis
1:31 and God saw everything that he had
made and behold it was very good and the
evening and the morning with the first
day right after that chapter 2 from
verse one thus the heavens and the Earth
were finished and all the hosts of them
and on the seventh day God ended his
work which he had made and he rested on
the seventh day from all his work which
he had made and God blessed the seven
day and Sanctified it because that in it
he had rested from all his work which
God created and made the Sabbath is a
memorial of creation Now creation is
much more important than some Christians
understand it is not by accident the
Bible begins with creation not with
salvation it begins with creation
Christ's role as Creator predated his
role as Savior and Will Survive his role
as Savior When sin is done away with
there will be no need for savior we will
always have a Creator as long as
anything exists that isn't God there
must be a Creator whether it's a star a
horse a bird a human being an angel as
long as anything exists outside the
father son and Holy Ghost there must be
a Creator and a sustainer and so the
Sabbath is a memorial on that day we are
to remember that we live because of God
we exist because of God we breathe
because of God we blink our eyes because
of God in him we live and move and have
our being Grass Grows because of God the
sun shines because of God we must be
aware of that Monday through Sunday but
on this special day we focus our
attention without the distraction of
secular activities on Christ's role as
Creator and sustainer of the entire
universe I can hear because the
processes that make that possible are
arranged and maintained by God I can
think because whatever happens in the
brain that allows me to do that is
controlled by the word of God God and so
creations and the Sabbath are
inseparable and the Sabbath by the way
is the key commandment of the 10 it
tells us who God is what his title is
and the domain of his authority the
Sabbath above all other the nine is the
preeminent commandment of the 10 there
is no separation between the Sabbath and
creation if the Sabbath had been
properly observed as ELO tells us there
would never have been an Atheist or an
idolator Sabbath keeping the biblical
way is an antidote to atheism and
idolatry it is no wonder it is the
Commandment the devil has attacked with
unsettling success and I say unsettling
because Satan cannot succeed unless
Humanity cooperates the Sabbath the
Sabbath the Sabbath is the Commandment
that
establishes God as Creator and the one
that shines most brightly of all the
other nine
Commandments indeed the Sabbath is
really linked to Creation it cannot be
separated from the creation account and
you also mentioned that the grasses grow
because by God's command and the Sun is
To Shine by God's command so how does
God preserve creation and good question
yeah and okay go ahead go ahead go ahead
go ahead precious and what did Sin do to
God's creation all right how does God
preserve creation let us go back to
Hebrews chapter 1 we read verse three we
read in verse two that creation was by
God verse three says who being the
brightness of his glory and the express
image of his person and upholding All
Things by the word of his power the word
that created is the very word that
sustains Colossians chapter 1 6 1617 for
by him were all things created that are
in heaven and that are in Earth visible
and invisible whether they be Thrones or
dominions or principalities or Powers
all things were created by Him and for
him and he is before all things and by
him all things consist now if we go back
to Second Peter 3 verse 5 and 7 for this
they willingly are ignorant of that by
the word of God they Heavens were of old
and the Earth standing out of the water
and in the water verse seven but the
Heaven and the Earth which are now by
the same word are kept in store the word
that creates is the word that maintains
and preserves the same word which also
brings this very important point if the
word that creates is the word that
maintains this tells us it has always
been God's desire that creation be
maintained at the same level of quality
at which it was
made because the same power that makes
it sustains it because of sin the
quality has fallen and the second part
of the question is what has sin done to
Creation sin has introduced destruction
into creation sin introduced death sin
introduced painful child birth sin
introduced thorns on roses sin
introduced wild animals sin introduced
murder sin sin introduced spous of abuse
sin introduced uh still birst sin
introduced every single thing that is
contrary to God's original plan of
Harmony Oneness in the entire universe
sin introduced the concept of an end
which is we know as
death the plan of creation is designed
to remove that and restore things to
what they were originally where they
would be no end and no death sinned
ruined creation gradually not overnight
gradually and the greatest ruin is seen
not in animals killing each other but in
human beings living like demons instead
of living like
God so sin has ruined every level of
creation is affected by Sin Sin affects
the very cells the very mitochondria sin
affects the Gen sin affects every single
thing the very air we breathe is Tainted
by sin that's why a brand new Heaven and
a brand new Earth have to be made Christ
won't improve this Earth or improve the
heaven associated with it he will
destroy both completely and remake them
all over
again there's nothing favorable to say
about
sin
nothing however attractive in May
because the devil told aeve for God does
know that in the day he eat thereof then
your eyes shall be open and he shall be
as God Satan specializes in packaging
sin attractively there is nothing
desirable about Sin Sin is anti- good
sin is anti- righteousness sin is anti-
happiness sin is anti Harmony sin is
anti-
eternity what an impact sin has not only
to our but to the creation you know
yes but H how does our understanding of
and the belief in the creation account
affect our relationship with God good
question there is physical creation and
there is is spiritual creation they both
are done the same way physical creation
was done by the word of God God created
out of nothing when God Saves a man or a
woman he creates out of nothing because
there is nothing you and I can offer to
God as raw materials with which he can
make a brand new being he creates us out
of nothing physical creation was done by
the word salvation is done by the word
James 1 verse 18 of his own will begat
he us with the word of Truth 1 Peter
chapter 1 verse 23 being born again not
of corruptible seed but Incorruptible by
the word of God and so the word that
creates is the word that saves the
process is the same the word of God
whether in physical creation or
spiritual and so as we contemplate
creation as we contemplate the Sabbath
it is a day to celebrate not only
physical creation but also spiritual
creation because if any man be in Christ
he is a new creation we are made again
it is called born again but we are
recreated in the image of God elwise
writes in education page 126 paragraph 4
the Creative Energy that call the worlds
into existence is in the word of God
this word begets power it imparts life
every command is a promise accepted by
the will receive into the soul it brings
with us the life of the infinite one it
transforms the nature and recreates the
soul in the image of God that is
spiritual creation whether physical or
spiritual the agency is the word of God
and so you cannot separate spiritual
creation from physical creation one
helps us understand the
other
powerful very powerful and you know
Elder SK thank thank you for posing
those questions you know you kind of
touched on the very last question that
we had which was what is the
significance of even the order of the
things that God created how how does the
creation or how does the creation mirror
excuse me how does Recreation mirror the
creation process um and just to
contextualize
this 2 Corinthians Chapter 4 verses 3
through6 and let me just quickly flip
there so that
we all hear
it 2 Corinthians 4: 3-6 where the Bible
says but if our gospel be hid it is hid
to them that are lost in whom the God of
this world hath blinded the the minds of
them which believe not lest the light of
the Glorious gospel of Christ who is the
image of God should shine in them and
let me skip in fact let me just read
verse not ourselves but Christ Jesus the
Lord and ourselves your servants for
Jesus's sake and this is a verse that
really makes the connection clear for
God who commanded the light to shine out
of Darkness has shined in our hearts to
give the light of the knowledge of the
glory of God in the face of Jesus so in
answering the last question that
precious posed Elder SK you mentioned
how Inseparable creation physical
creation is from spiritual Recreation so
just bring how can we unpack that some
more how does even the creation account
even the Order of Things that were
created mirror the process of conversion
that the child of God must undergo to
become like him well if you look at
verse six it says for God who commanded
the light to shine out of Darkness have
shine in our hearts to give the light of
the knowledge of the glory of God in the
face of Jesus Paul is clearly quoting
Genesis 1:3 and God said let it be light
and there was light if you connect that
to 2 Corinthians 4:6 it is obvious Paul
considers let they be light to be a
command because he says for God who
commanded the light to shine out of
darkness and so let there be light it
was a command let there be light or
firmament or grass whatever they were
all commands creation came into
existence by the command of God when a
person is born again the commands are
written on the person 's heart you see
because the Commandments represent the
righteousness of God righteousness by
faith is no different from obedience by
faith it is the same thing because
righteousness is right doing
righteousness is Conformity to the law
of God and so in Salvation the law of
God is written by God on the heart of
the person who comes to Christ and so
the the command that made light and
there was light the command written in
the of the person brings to the person
the light of the Life of Christ because
Christ is the light of the world he's
the light of the individual the law is
life the law is light the law is
righteousness the law is truth the law
is everything the law reflects the very
Life of Christ and so by command light
came and that same command by the same
person is written on the heart of the
person then Jesus could say let your
light so shine because the the law of
God is light Thy word is a lamp unto my
feet and a light unto my path and the
highest expression of God's word is his
law if there' been no sin we would still
have had the law the highest expression
of God's word is his law and his law is
a lamp unto my feet and a light unto my
path there's a command in physical
creation there's a command in spiritual
creation God does not command you to be
saved but when you call upon him he
writes this Commandments on your heart
why because saving you from sin is
saving you from Disobedience to his
commands he saves you from Disobedience
to obedience is as simple as that you
cannot be one with God unless you're one
with his
Commandments Conformity with God is
Conformity with God's law which
expresses his
righteousness powerful Elder SK powerful
you know it's so interesting because God
has exalted his word above his name
Psalm 138 verse2 yes yes and you're
speaking about us conforming to the
commands of God which is so we conform
to the commands of God we are allow
ourselves to become like God for his
character to be within us if you look at
the the Genesis account I've said this
many times it may become tedious in
Genesis 2:16 and the Lord God commanded
the man saying of every tree the garden
that was a command in Genesis 3:11 and
Adam or 3:10 Adam said I heard thy voice
in the garden I was afraid because I was
naked and I hid myself and he said who
told thee that thou was naked hast thou
eaten of the tree whereof I commanded
thee we have command again verse 17 and
unto Adam he said because thou Hast
hearkened unto the voice of thy wife and
has eaten of the tree of which I
commanded thee sing We have Genesis 216
command Genesis 3:11 command Genesis
3:17 command the problem was command was
broken that led to sin there is no way
to sin unless you break the
Commandments and there's no way to be
saved unless you made one with the law
of
God amen amen amen now Elder SK you know
we've done all of this discussion on
creation looking at the Genesis account
its relationship to the Sabbath its
relationship even to our Salvation and
Recreation but there are some who don't
even count this account as
credible as credible and we know there
are varying uh views or ideas of how
this world came into being and one of
the theories um that is touted by you
the scientific world and perhaps The
World At Large is the theory of
evolution right right well it's the
World At Large you're quite right The
World At Large and that's really the
prevailing Theory it may have a lot of
relatives is the prevailing Theory now
no one ever calls God a liar I've never
heard anyone call God a liar no one now
here's what the Bible says when people
say there's no God there's no creation
it's a serious exercise in
denial let's go to Romans chapter 1 and
hear what a God that cannot lie has told
us Romans 1 let's read verse 20 maybe
sister precious can read for us Romans
chapter 1 verse
20 it says for the invisible things of
him from the creation of the world are
clearly seen being understood by the
things that are made even stop stop stop
now let's read that microscopically for
the invisible things of him from the
creation of the world are clearly seen
That's What God Says being understood
how by the things that are made even his
eternal power and godhead so that they
are without excuse the word godhead
there means the Divinity of God so that
they are without it now the Bible says
people are without excuse when they say
there's no God there's no creation
there's no creator God himself has said
the evidence of his existence is
overwhelming to the point no one has an
excuse and so to be an atheist must be
is it is necessary to engage in constant
denial constant denial because God has
said you are surrounded by evidence that
there is a God to such a degree you are
without
excuse and so I am not Disturbed or
distress when people say there's no God
they are simply denying an overwhelming
reality and that's not
strange you look around there people are
always denying reality whether January 6
the capital attack or people call it a
picnic a peaceful protest people just
deny reality if it suits them and people
Den you see people are fundamentally
opposed to the concept of God not God is
someone who lives but but God who is
holy God who is righteous God who
specializes in Integrity the caral
nature is opposed to that the carnal
nature is not opposed to a being
existing the carnal nature is opposed to
Holiness righteousness goodness
Integrity sinlessness Perfection God
represents all of that and so we deny
God despite the overwhelming abundance
of evidence there is a God and so the
invisible things of him from the
creation of the world are clearly seen
being understood by the things that are
made what are the things that are made
trees flowers animals the Sun the moon
all of creation represents an
irresistible argument there is a
God amen amen amen thank you for that
Elder ski now interestingly enough there
are people that believe in what's called
theistic Evolution yes is that God
created the world through Evolution I
mean are we even able to reconcile can
we reconcile the creation account with
Evolution you cannot reconcile oil and
water it's as simple as that there is
nothing in creation that allows for uh
Evolution as the explanation for the
existence of Life are you follow me let
me say that Clearly
Now there may be some changes that take
place in people over time for instance
if you live where the sun is always
shining your eyes may become slitted
after a while if you're always walking
you may Dev you may have very flat seat
so you can grip branches whatever that
may have yes you call that Evolution or
you call that some sort of change of
adaptation but evolution as an
explanation for existence is
anti-biblical and it is opposed
overwhelmingly by creation you cannot
harmonize Evolution and creation because
when you do that you remove God
now this theistic Evolution It also says
God created the world and left it to
R he has no here you go you're on your
own go on no no no no no the Bible says
the word that created is the word that
sustains and so that overthrows theistic
Evolution that God made it and left it
to run itself no the Bible is clear
second Peter 35 and 7 the same word that
creates in verse 5 sustains in verse 7
Hebrews 1 ver5 all things are upheld by
the word of his power Colossians 1:17 he
upholds all
things and all things in him consist and
so Evol uh creation has no room not even
a slight accommodation for the
principles of evolution as an
explanation for creation and the origin
of Life absolutely
not amen amen Elder SK and I evolution
by the way is the most widespread
religion on the face of the Earth
because you have to believe that that
all that we see came out of nothing you
really
have to believe that set aside reason
common sense and there are people with
phds who believe that
R
not there's an intelligent power behind
orderly
world powerful and of course the source
of evolution is
Satan escape the source of creation is
Christ so Christ and Satan again at
War you brought up you know race go
ahead brought up two ideas in my mind
you know as I was looking there are some
assumptions so number one as you
stated If theistic evolution was so then
God would have had to have left the
Earth to run on its own and one of the
other reasons that the two cannot be
reconciled is the dating I mean based on
the generations from Adam the Earth is
about 6,000 years old whereas in
evolution the idea is that the Earth is
like millions billions of years old and
radio radioactive dating yes yes yeah
billions to go with that there are
certain assumptions that need to be made
so they have to believe these
assumptions in order to have their
dating and it really does show that it's
a religion a belief I'll just read some
of the assumptions so it is a belief it
is a
belief so number one that a change in
the isotopic radiations ra ratios has
taken place since the rock crystallized
right so okay they're pretty much saying
that from the time The Rock was formed
there were changes in that I guess in
the elements that it's composed of right
and The Rao always always been that the
same you have to assume was changed from
the original conditions to the present
conditions by radio so they're saying
that what was always was and also that
one can know or estimate the original
concentration of the parent and daughter
Isotopes in the Rock so a whole bunch of
technological terms but at the end of
the they are assuming or extrapolating
that something is true and they're
choosing to believe it instead the word
yeah cons let me introduce since most
people not familiar with radio the
dating system you mentioned there a
theological defense we can produce it is
the only self sustaining thing in the
universe is
God Only God the son God the Holy Ghost
God the Father can sustain self-
sustaining everything else must be
sustained by that power so when when you
say God created the universe and left it
to run itself then if it's running
itself it becomes a God to itself are
you following me only God can sustain
selves everything else depends on God
that is why the Sabbath is so important
the Sabbath principle is all of creation
depends on God and so if there's
anything in creation that sustains
itself that thing is God and you cannot
have the godhead and some other God
somewhere theistic Evolution that evolu
uh creation runs itself is to introduce
the concept of another God Only God can
sustain himself that's why the Bible
says in him we live and move and have
our being with the plants animals
inanimate objects like rocks or whatever
they are all sustained the tides by God
the Moon by God the Sun by God the stars
in the trist courses El refer to them by
God there is no such thing as a self
sustaining entity outside of
God amen amen now I'll close off this
question with h this quotation from
Patriarchs and Prophets page 44
paragraph
three says there is no ground for the
supposition that was evolved by slow
degrees of development from the lower
forms of animal or vegetable
life teaching lowers the great work of
the Creator to the level of man's narrow
Earthly conceptions yes yes well
put amen well
put amen
creation and the
Sabbath you see Lucifer was tired of
depending upon God he wanted to be his
own God he wanted to be self- sustaining
you see and anyone who dismisses God is
following in the same line I will
sustain myself that is impossible you
are sustained by God that's why the
Bible says he make his son to rise on
the evil and on The Good the sun
represents life and sendeth rain on the
just and the unjust the rain represents
life you cannot live apart from God you
cannot exist apart from God any theory
that tells you that is a theory that
seeks to set
another
God Amen and amen
amen well Alis we have concluded our
core questions all right and we have
probably about a little about 15 minutes
okay open form questions related to the
topic of the creation right so okay I
see Brandon Gilbert Brandon
Gilbert has put in the
chat who does Proverbs 8: 22-31 refer to
through Jesus
Christ when describing someone that was
with God in
creation Everlasting yet brought forth
at some prior to Creation I think we
addressed this question before one time
on a I know a long time ago yes it
refers to Christ brought forth doesn't
mean created just made
manifest not created made manif sealed
not
created a Creator cannot have a
Creator
Amen brother Brandon I hope I hope that
you he have to do some study but that
person I was with him as one brought up
that's Christ that's Solomon discussing
the Eternal connection between Father
and Son you see when you read the Bible
always keep in mind even though they
were inspired it did not make them more
than human they were Still Human all
human beings have limitations they are
trying to discuss Eternal things using a
human mind despite the role of the Holy
Ghost but the Holy Ghost does not change
you from being human so you still have
limitations when El white wrote she
tried to describe what she saw using a
limited
brain but that refers to Jesus Christ
wisdom yes and Elder SK interestingly
enough we received a question from
YouTube uh Sister Dean frame had
actually submitted this before kind of
on the same realm of okay yes Jesus Is
God but what does it mean when God calls
him his only begotten son he's one of a
kind one of a kind there's an Earthly
version of that which is
Isaac Isaac is called Abraham's only
begotten son he's one of a kind because
he was not gotten because of the
biological power of Abraham he was
begotten by the direct intervention of
God Isaac was one of a kind that's why
God can say to Abraham in Genesis 22:1
after these things the Lord did temp
Abraham and said un him Abraham he said
here I am he said take now thy son thine
only son Isaac whom thou lovest he
wasn't the only son because ishel was
existing before he was but God is
referring to the One of a Kind status of
Isaac Christ is one of a
kind came from the
dead by his own
power not made
he came from the dead he is one of a
kind monogan unique unlike anybody
else there's this uh this belief
drifting through adventism that Christ
had a beginning no Divine being can have
a
beginning if you got a beginning you're
not
God not only that go to Genesis not
Genesis go to Romans 1:25 quickly let me
show you something that's very dangerous
about that
belief Romans 1 let's read verse
25 ready it says who changed the truth
of God into a lie and worshiped and
served the Creator more than the Creator
who is blessed forever amen now the
great crime that the Ancients had well
and moderns against God is they worship
the creature instead of the Creator are
you following me yeah now read verse
26 it says for this cause God gave the
up unto vile affections for even their
woman did change the natural use into
that which is against nature so God gave
them up after a while they kept
worshiping the creature above the
Creator now that's a crime against God
is it the crime of crime it's idolatry
and God hated idolatry because idolatry
is an attempt to replace him now if you
say Christ at the beginning he's a
creature and if you worship Him you are
worshiping a creature
let me slow down and be less passionate
let me say
SL if you say Christ had a beginning
Christ is part of creation he's a crean
and if you worship Him you are doing
what the Ancients did in really angering
God by worshiping creation instead of
the Creator if you say Christ at the
beginning you are worshiping a created
being and the Bible is absolutely
against that Christ had no Christ has
always been
there amen amen and let me just check
YouTube quickly and see if there are any
questions on this never doubt the
Eternal nature of Christ he has all
always been
there amen amen so friends if you have a
question on this topic the creation that
you would like to directly ask to Elder
ski feel free to use the raise your hand
feature will
okays so feel free to use the raise your
hand feature and then we will allow you
to unmute so we will okay you should be
able to unmute now for there
Edwards yes hello can you hear me yes
yes yes yes yes happy Sabbath Pastor SK
same to you my good brother God bless
you my question to you is when it's when
God says that he created us in his own
image what what does image signifies
does it signifies in visual Outlook or
is it speaking about character lifestyle
live like how God is let us go to uh
Hebrews chapter 12 precious read verse
10 for
us Hebrews
12:10 then we'll go to 2 Peter chapter 1
ver4 then we'll go to Philippians
2:5 all right Hebrews 12:10 it says for
they which verily for a few days chasen
us after their own pleasure but he for a
prophet
Prophet that we might be partakers of
his Holiness now we are to be partakers
of God's holiness that has always been
God's will for us now in in that passage
Paul is contrasting human parents with
our divine parent human parents
sometimes punish us because we make them
look bad God punishes us that we might
partake of his Holiness now let's go to
Second Peter chapter 1 read verse
4 it says whereby are given unto us
exceeding great and precious promises
that by these ye might be partakers of
the divine nature having escaped the
corruption that is in the world through
lost through the word of God we partake
of the divine nature of God that's how
we connect to the divine nature of God
through the word of God read that verse
against his oppression I don't mean to
overwork you let's listen
microscopically it says whereby are
given unto us exceeding great and
precious promises that's the word of God
that's the word of God exceeding great
and precious promises now keep reading
carefully that by these by these by
these what the great and precious
promises go on ye might be partakers of
the divine
nature having escaped the corruption
that is in the world through lost
through the abiding of God's word in us
we come into contact with the divine
nature of God and it makes a tremendous
change in our lives now let's go to
Philippians chapter 2
verse5 it's a very familiar
verse let this mind be in you which was
also in Christ Jesus five now let's put
all those together Hebrews 12:10 we must
partake of the Holiness of God second
Peter 1:4 we must partake of the divine
nature of God Philippians 2:5 we must
have the mind of Christ clearly it is
the character of God but now go to John
chapter 5 John 5 read verse
37 and the father himself which had sent
me had borne witness of me now read very
carefully ye have needed the ne ye have
nether heard his voice at any time uhhuh
nor seen his shape ah God has a shape
now we don't know what it is God has a
shape Jesus said that you haven't heard
his voice you haven't seen his shape now
Patriarchs and Prophets page 45
paragraph 2 El white right man was to
Bear God's image both in outward
resemblance and in
character I hope that satisfies my
handsome brother who put the question
man was to Bear God's image both in
outward resemblance and in character of
course character being preeminent of
course always is but somehow on the
outside something about us look like
Goden amen we'll see exactly what that
is when we see him but Jesus said you've
neither heard his voice at any time nor
seen his shape El white was Envision she
was led by Christ she was taken up and
she saw a tremendous light she asked
Christ what's that he said as the father
she said does he have a shape Jesus said
yes does he have a form Christ said yes
he said can I see him Jesus said
absolutely not can't you die thank you
Pastor thank you my brother God bless
you thank you you
too amen thank you brother Edwards for
joining and for asking that question and
thank you Al SK for
answering we have one question here
brother Brandon has put this in the chat
brother Brandon would you like to unmute
and ask your question directly or do you
want me to just read
it well go go ahead and read it so he
says I'm not sure if this was previously
addressed but what was the light created
on the first day given that the natural
sources of light were created on
subsequent days that being the fourth
day of the creation week I have I don't
have a satisfactory answer to that I've
tried I've not yet come to a
satisfactory answer to that
sorry but I've already asked many time I
do not yet have a satisfactory answer
that's
biblical but God won't create something
that's already been there that's right
so there's some change some
difference
well all right so I think that is the
end if no one
else you would like to like to ask to
Alis on this topic I guess that's the
end thank you so much to those of you
that are on Zoom let me just call you
all by name my
mother yes amen m love you sister Alana
quashi sister Beverly thank you for
Faithfully joining may God continue to
bless your keep hope alive
Ministry and okay I see sister Claire
you have raised your hand so let me
pause then you can unmute and ask your
question on the
creation sister Claire it sounds like
you're at say something but the audio is
very low are you able to put like your
phone or microphone closer to your
mouth connected sorry I was I was
speaking through a Bluetooth um sorry I
I had a baby here I have a baby here
that's why I had put my my question in
the chart I said happy Sabbath to
everybody I put my question in the chart
but I don't think you you've seen it yet
um it's uh in the book of Pat and
Prophets M uh um I I was not here from
the beginning I'm sorry but I just
thought that you guys were online and I
thought I would ask a question and it
was about
creation uh it says on page
um 34 and paragraph
one I it's somewhere in the middle of
the paragraph actually it says the Lord
proceed me in the beginning of his way
before his works of old I was set up
from
Everlasting yeah we dealt with
that and that that is a reference to
Jesus Christ who has always been with
the father
Yes makes that very clear in her
writings that's Jesus Christ in Proverbs
chapter 8 is probably what you're
reading from Proverbs
8 it's so yeah so set up from
Everlasting does that mean he was
created by God no no no let me say no in
as many languages as I can Christ is the
creator Christ was not
created right if you read Genesis 1:1 in
the beginning God created the Heaven and
the earth now in that verse there are
two levels of existence you either exist
as God or you exist as part of creation
that's the only way to exist there isn't
a third level Christ is the creator the
Bible says he's before all things if
someone is before all things that person
cannot be created it would mean that
something before him created him Christ
has always
existed
always you read Psalm 90 from verse one
Lord thou Hast been our Dwelling Place
in all generation before the heavens
were brought forth orever thou has
formed the earth and the world even from
Everlasting to Everlasting Thou Art God
now how long is one
Everlasting Moses wrote that Psalm is
trying to express the Eternal nature of
Christ and he says from Everlasting to
Everlasting he doubles up on
Everlasting Christ has always
existed with the
father by the way the Holy Ghost as well
that that that was a little confusing to
me because I was thinking like like just
just like as a human being you have a
child there's you and then you have a
child you have existed of course you
have existed before the child yeah you
see Christ is not the Christ is not the
Eternal Christ the Creator is not the
biological son of the father he is the
son because he's just like the father in
the Bible the word son can mean several
things a grandson can be the son of the
grandfather a son can also be someone
who's just like and so James and John
before they were converted were called
the sons of thunder now Thunder did not
give birth to James and John but they
called the sons of thunder Judas was
called the son of predition but pedition
did not get pregnant and produced Judas
because of what he did to Christ he's
called the son of predition James and
John because they were loud and noisy
are called the sons of thunder the
Antichrist is called the son of
predition son of in the Bible can mean
just
like okay well now I it okay sister
there you get now hold on to it don't
lose it thank you so much God bless you
you're welcome and God bless that baby
thank you thank
you amen amen amen and amen thank you
all for joining I see sister Beverly yes
she said Elder SK thanks again for
enlightening enlightening
us may God continue to bless your
ministry and great job precious praise
the Lord praise God yes we are not
forgetting those of you on YouTube
Welcome sister camell from Guyana my
parents home
Guyana and Guana nice place the land of
Peppa pot yes God bless Guyana amen
thank you we receive
it and those of you that are here if
Atlas Oscar Shane Steve and those of you
that here on Zoom I think I mentioned a
few of you let me come to the
participants there's not too many of us
here so I think I can acknowledge all of
you sister kiss Pastor Steven boo
Brandon and sister Alana quashi there's
someone called boo yes Pastor St is that
person from Barbados he's not well you
know what maybe
Pastor by now I'm going to allow you to
unmute so you can probably bring some
clarity yeah my my family are from
Barbados Ah that's the root 1800 1800
okay well God bless you that's a good
name thank you you're welcome yeah see
look at that I didn't even know I
allowed Meo so I know he's from St
Vincent but look at that Tracing Our
Roots you know imagine what heaven will
be like you know when we all get
together and we're like let's go to this
place let's go to well you know what
we'll see we'll see how it is but can't
wait to be there thank you so much Elder
SK your time for your devotion you know
the fever with which you divide the word
of God we are grateful for your
commitment to this
work God be praised God be praised I
really mean that amen may the Lord
continue to strengthen you as you
continue with the Revival at Wayne
you thank put his words in your mouth
restore your strength and many blessings
to your lovely wife sister
SK to put his angels to guard round
about her thank you thank you so much
Elder for your time okay we love you
thank you so much oh I love you too God
bless you God bless you amen
amen all right friends so with that
being said we typically have a
meditative song song and this afternoon
sister precious and I will be just
singing together I surrender all you
know we want to commit Our
Lives to God's word you know aler SK
this afternoon spoke about us conforming
Our Lives to the very righteousness of
Christ that Foundation his word his
character his law his Truth The
Commandments of God being Upon Our
Hearts may we surrender to him today
amen
All to
Jesus I
surrender all to him I
freely
give I
[Music]
will
love and trust him
in his
presence
daily
live
I
surrender
all I
all
all to him my
blessed
savior
I
surrender
all All to
Jesus
I
[Music]
surender
humbly at his feet I
bow
worldly
pleasures
all
forsaken
take me
Jesus take me
now
I
surrender all
surrender
all
all to thee my
blessed
savior
I
[Music]
surrender
all
All to
Jesus
I
Surrender make me
savior
holy
thine
fill me with thy
love and
Power
truly know that thou art
mine
I
surrender
all
I
surrender
all oh all to thee my
blessed
savior
I
surrender
[Music]
all
All to
Jesus
I
[Music]
Surrender
now I feel
the
sa
flame
oh the joy of
full
salvation
glory
glory to his
name
I
surren
all
I
surrender
all
oh
all to thee my
blessed
savior
I
Surrender
surren
Ro
I
Surrender
[Music]
oh
all to thee my bless
blessed
savior
I
surender
all amen amen amen may we surrender all
to our creator Redeemer sustainer and
sooncoming King even now thank you all
for joining us this afternoon and I sh
should not forget those of you that were
on Facebook Twitter and twitch we
appreciate your presence stay tuned for
next month maybe having some Outreach
maybe another Q&A but stay tuned for the
fourth Sabbath of February God willing
at 2:00 p.m. Eastern Standard time we
will be having something so keep that
date marked but at the end of it all may
we be found faithful we've heard the
word but now it is the time to live the
word in fact today the pastor that
preached at my church uh Dr charlay said
that between effort excuse me between
expectation and execution is effort so
may we allow the Holy Spirit to work in
us may we put forth our efforts so that
we can receive the coming of our Lord
and savior with joy and gladness so
let's stay faithful and God willing
we'll see you next month take care and
God bless bye oh and thank you so much
precious oh it's a pleasure praise God
praise the Lord I should say my dear
sister is also a medical school she's
soon to graduate so praise God for her
ministry as well and thank you all for
your presence thank you Mom for all of
your prayers love and support and so
once again all of you that are here from
the bottom of my heart thank you and
Elder Randy SK God bless you abundantly
thank you for your dedication to this
ministry friends until next time we
shall